when I was 20 I stopped talking for like
three months I didn't know what was
wrong it was dark the only time I used
my voice was at night
I would walk by myself and I would sing
I never sang before then I needed to
listen to the voice inside of me to find
out what my purpose was I decided I
remember I was like I'm gonna be a
singer I'm liberal I am a rapper I'm a
singer I'm a songwriter and I live in
Los Angeles California once I decided to
become a singer my mission became very
clear to me I music is activism because
my mere existence as a musician is
activism and I want you to use the song
to activate you to make the world a
better place real well big girl needs
work okay don't see black women you
don't see big girls like me and that
should change I want to see tons of
plus-size pop stars I want to see black
girl magic I just want to see us way
more imagine a heaven where all of the
angels and goddesses are thick and
voluptuous in just chrome specific need
a crown no dude I'm a queen growing up
in Detroit I was raised very very very
strict Pentecostal couldn't go to the
movies couldn't listen to secular music
it was the devil hey stop sue a perfect
when you're finding your voice you can't
have any restrictions on yourself you
can't have any fear so I had to let go
of all of that to find my voice and see
a little ratchet but my family still
loves her ha ha ha ha you one more I'll
let you go
ok i'ma try myself up I do MA
I wouldn't be here if I didn't stop
talking three-month I wouldn't be here
if I didn't tell myself to be a singer
everything else actually just started
falling into place
that's what finding your purpose is all
about the universe conspires with you
[Music]
baby how you prove
[Music]